I would like to show you a little bit about how a tool that my research group created
called Csmith works, and so Csmith is just a random test case generator.
We use it to try break C compilers. Let's just take a little bit of a look and see how it works.
What I'm going to do here is shell into a machine belonging to my group.
And we're going to look at an in-progress Csmith run that's been going for a couple of days.
So let's see the results. Let's see what happened. Okay.
So here's what happened over the last couple of days with this testing run.
So what I'm doing is making a program using Csmith and then using the latest version of GCC
and the latest version of clang that is LLVM C front-end to compile each test case
with a variety of optimization levels.
And I'm not using any kind of weird optimization levels.
I'm basically just compiling it. -00, -01, -02.
And it doesn't matter if you're not a C compiler user.
These are basically the sort of vanilla compiler optimization levels that any compiler user
would probably be using so what the bottom of this output shows us is that 150 thousand tests
have ran since I started this testing run and during this testing run GCC has failed
a half dozen times or so, clang has failed a few times, and also we see a few Csmith failures.
It could be that the Csmith failures are actual bugs but historically speaking most of the time
these are timeouts and so generally all of these tools are ran in their timeouts
when we use a random testing loop because random test tend to be really good at finding
performance pathologies but the tool runs for a really long time.
And that wastes time so what we do is we just kill any tool after it has ran for several minutes
including our random test case generator itself so let's see what we can learn here.
So what I'm going to do is look and see if we found any interesting LLVM failures.
And so when LLVM crashes it always tells us how it crashed using an assertion violation.
And so as I've discussed a couple of units ago, many real programs contain a lot of assertions
and these compilers certainly have that property. Okay.
So what we can see is that LLVM has crashed it looks like 4 times here.
One time with a message about wrong topological sorting.
And 3 times with a message about unknown live-in to the entry block.
And it turns out that I happen to know that this wrong topological sorting bug is not new.
This is the one that I reported a couple of weeks ago.
On the other hand, this unknown live-in to the entry block bug is probably new.
So one thing we could do is check in LLVM's Bugzilla if this actually is new,
but what I'm going to do now is just assume that it is and let's take a little bit of a look at this bug.
So here we are in the actual log of Csmith's output.
And that it's telling us is what command line arguments it used when it invoked Csmith
to generate the program that killed clang.
And so what you can see is it contains a bunch of options but also it contains the random number
seed that Csmith uses so we're going to need to cut and paste this,
and we can pass this to a different script, which is going to generate this program again.
And let's edit it. Let's look at it.